fraqueza antes e depois de menstruar
pode ser hormonal e o que fazer bem a
fraqueza antes e depois da menstruação
ela pode ser influenciada por vários
fatores várias razões e Isso inclui
fatores hormonais nutricionais e de
estilo de vida é importante
primeiramente pensar entender que as
flutuações hormonais durante esse ciclo
menstrual podem afetar sim a energia e o
bem-estar geral Então os níveis de
progesterona estrogênio eles vão variar
de forma significativa ao longo do c
E essas mudanças podem levar a sintomas
como fadiga fraqueza e mudança de humor
então além de gente pensar nos fatores
hormonais temos que pensar em outros
fatores por exemplo a deficiência de
nutrientes essenciais pode estar tendo
deficiência de Ferro vitaminas do
complexo B magnésio isso tudo pode estar
contribuindo pra fraqueza então a perda
de sangue que acontece em cada ciclo em
cada menstruação pode levar uma
deficiência sim do mineral essencial
Ferro especialmente se a dieta não
estiver adequada não for rica em Fonte
de Ferro como é o caso de Carnes
vermelhas legumes e frutas secas então
para aliviar a fraqueza relacionada à
menstruação eu vou dar aqui algumas
dicas algumas sugestões primeiramente
alimentação é sempre essencial vamos
adotar uma alimentação equilibrada rica
em nutrientes incluindo alimentos fontes
de Ferro vitaminas do complexo B e
magnésio frutas legumes nozes e sementes
são excelentes opções e se necessário
vamos repor o ferro com suplementos à
base desse mineral e também vitaminos do
Complexo B magnésio sempre com
orientação de médico ou nutricionista
hidratação é importante beber bastante
água isso é crucial para manter energia
e bem-estar atividade física regular e
de não muita intensidade pode ser
caminhada pode ser qualquer tipo de
exercício aeróbico mais suave ou yoga
que vai ajudar a melhorar a energia e
reduzir essa fadiga e gerenciar o
estresse com técnica de relaxamento
meditação respiração profunda isso vai
ajudar a reduzir o estresse e melhorar a
energia é muito importante ter um
descanso adequado então certifique-se de
dormir o suficiente manter um horário de
sono regular em termos de suplementos de
substâncias naturais Você tá podendo
utilizar chás herbais é uma boa chá de
ervas como o chá de Valeriana ou chá de
camomila podem ajudar reduzir a
ansiedade e ajudar no descanso e
terapias complementares como acupultura
massagem pode ajudar aliviar a fadiga e
melhorar a energia